I want a great family like I do not want  to be a single mother so I will always  pick um I don't care about how much  money you are I don't care about  protector I need a man that's going to  be a good father to my children and  usually those are men that are good  communicating so so this is this is I'm  just gonna tell you what remember what  you said this is contradicting what you  said because if you don't care about  money then you don't care if he's  ambitious  and that's if you don't remember earlier  you were talking about how you didn't  care so much about money you care more  about emotionally and I don't care about  him paying for me because I'm ambitious  but I'm saying then so so if you're  ambitious if you're ambitious  okay okay okay but I know so that  translates into money in the future